Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to a
treatise from Boston? A treatise from Boston.
Welcome back to the program. How's it going?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, Good to talk to you again.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 2: Eva, quick question. I remember a few
months ago we briefly talked about ranked choice
voting yes. And I can remember three or four years
ago it not being a very well-known system,
but after Alaska adopted it and it's at least
blamed on Sarah Palin losing. I'm wondering if
do you think that with things like that, like it
being aiding in a Democrat winning, or at least,
you know, blaming it with Sarah Palin's loss and
things like that, do you think that it all kind of
it's progress in being adopted nationwide will be
stagnated just by these right wing talking points
of that? It's just a tool by the left to, you
know, tyranny of the majority, that sort of thing.
Speaker 1: I don't think it will help. And it's
sort of similar to movements to move from an
electoral College system to a national popular
vote are limited by a number of different factors.
But many Republicans are aware that were it not
for the electoral vote, if we had a national
popular vote, there's a whole bunch of there
winners who would have actually lost. So it is
without question that at least the Republicans
that pay attention know that popular vote isn't
great for them. The extent to which they know that
that transferable vote or ranked choice voting is
bad for them. I think it's less clear. But I do
think that the Sarah Palin situation in Alaska
is a cautionary tale. You know, the truth is,
in the midst of all the insanity of the last
year, it hasn't been a topic anyone's been
talking about too much. So it actually could be
an opportunity to make some progress on ranked
choice voting for dedicated activists.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I would say like,
definitely now. Well, it's not as in the
mainstream. I think it kind of was within
like the few months before the midterms. But
after all, that kind of got lost in the shuffle.
Speaker 1: I agree.
Speaker 2: Well, one other quick note.
Thank you for that. I do have one quick follow up
question. Do you have a favorite political movie?
Speaker 1: Not really. I mean, I think as far as
a documentary, I actually forget the name of it,
but it's a documentary from when Paul Begala and
James Carville ran Bill Clinton's campaign. What
is it called The War Room now? I don't remember.
It's it's a good documentary. I don't really watch
too many political movies, to be honest.
Speaker 2: Mm hmm. Mm hmm. Yeah. I mean,
this one in ten hour of quality, but fair.
Thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. A treatise from
Boston. Great to hear from you again.